oh my god look who it is how are you
yeah we still have beef after all
there's no beef what do you mean we both
matching we've grown up right we've both
you've matured or you're looking much
well now i mean finally
would you just say i said her you know
she used to work with bow wow
the guy that you casted yes
i'm sorry this is back then that was
sheila jaffee
no this is back when i needed the role
she was bow wow's uh cause there were
counterparts and this was at a time
where he was doing the show that you
didn't want me on
that's right mr self-sabotage himself
okay
well all right well hey hi the
background is is setting the tone
mark i wasn't prepared for the new
diddy like
like i'm not mad at it but i wasn't
ready i wasn't ready to sound like
you're not happy with it are you okay it
doesn't sound like you're happy with it
are you okay with your truth this ain't
about me
when my wife and my kids saw it they
were like completely shocked nobody knew
okay because i was like is this still a
family member yeah but you're giving off
like an ill thing like you're like what
was your what are you saying i wasn't
ready what does that mean that's what
i'm saying we're not doing this today
i'm asking what does that mean not here
well you did you see it and were you
like oh where are you like i talked
about it
i was shook it and then i was concerned
for your well-being okay were you
traumatized how are you doing
emotionally i mean the question i wasn't
traumatized you know you got to know it
wasn't scripted that he was supposed to
hold me like that all right okay first
of all yeah
you clearly see where my hands are
uh we did a poll we did a focus group
and we were like look mark wahlberg what
do people want what people want to see
it came up huh booty cheeks no that's
not what happened
okay so this is the duo i didn't know i
needed i really enjoyed this so i have
to ask you
how does kevin fare
up against the likes of will ferrell and
ted oh don't do that um
[Music]
because i've been wondering this the
whole goddamn time
i've been wanting to know where i stand
this whole time
well
if we put you on an apple box you'll be
standing right there that's a
sorry just a little hanging oh my god
no um i gotta tell you
kevin like will
are some of the kindest sweetest people
who absolutely happen to be some of the
funniest people on the planet but their
comedy comes from a nice place and they
just enjoy making people laugh yeah so
uh
i hold this man in the highest regard
possible what does that mean
yeah what'd you just say just close
behind will what does that mean
it's hard for you it's hard to be will
not well is it sweet it's hard to be
willing but how does mark compare to
dwayne
my shirt just got tight all right
listen if we're going to answer the
question can i get the oil all right i
need the oil let's take the band-aid and
rip it off because the people want to
know
if you got salt at the end of the day
take the top twist it put the salt
behind you it's going to leave a trail
right
cayenne pepper is only hot if you taste
it twice okay all right so let's do it
you understand what i'm saying if you're
going to walk the beat of a drummer
here's my thing are you using your hands
or sticks
right
there you go i gave it to you straight
what is that what does it mean
i mean i can't be no more honest than
that
if a pig is going oink what's his tail
look like
huh
okay
come on now he's done some random teeth
don't make me explain it to you yeah
next question thank you right thank you
you can't clap with all hands can you
thank you
thank you
all right thank you thank you